the adventure its action face they
enjoy a piece of being said yes but
history we wanted to bring a share
of actions both for a question of
rhythm and especially for a question
of emotion that we want to convey to the
player  to think a little bit off the
beaten path to bring
something different to the players also
it's not a war game it's
more a game about war in
which we will go through the time of the
world war one
sk families want a reality
fisher street style of gameplay
each character has their own purpose we will
try to take the player thinking like a
dog to the world in the game they
represent an almost childish
look at the reality of war
pf at the  'horizon super qui la world game
not only i will be your best friend to
dope their boots also in visual link
between the characters and will go from
one character to the other and i will
there i help you to solve puzzle to 10 3
canals mise  to  find collective old
mutual collectibles hidden away in the
game
they love each other aim emotion and gamble
a letter to their character at 2007
they blacked away and we try to adapt
the grand prize of all of them to how they
were being must confess this  be a
jackpot you sure that for him it's
but black